[Musique]
je m'appelle à tomber j'ai 11 ans
j'habite à québec il nous sommes cinq
dans ma famille je suis très sportive
j'adore entre autres le football et la
gym ans et j'ai également plusieurs
compétitions de vélo de montagne
j'ai mes blagues je suis très sociable à
l'aide d'une courte anecdote je sais pas
vous faire découvrir les deux côtés de
la médaille quand tarifs du gaz
l'utilisation des appareils
électroniques je sais pas pour vous mais
moi des fois je me demande si on devrait
toujours faire confiance à nos appareils
électroniques avant de continuer sur ce
sujet j'aimerais vous raconter
l'histoire d'edward gagne c'est monsieur
allard d'être nomade comme le tout dans
la lutte et non pour moi le changement
dans le début de la carrière d'edouard
sinden il travaillait dans l'armée
américaine
m'est avis qu'il s'était trop souvent
cassé la jambe deux fois il a arrêté de
travailler dans l'action mais les métros
servir son pays alors il décida de
continuer à le servir en sait trop bien
dans la central intelligence
si vous préférez la siagne mais à la
centrale le découvrir quelque chose qui
ne le plus pas vraiment il découvrit que
l'agencé des méthodes contre la loi pour
obtenir dans ces marchés à un rythme si
méthode consistait à pouvoir voir tout
ce qu'on envoie à nos amis ils pouvoir
voir tout ce qu'on fait à partir de la
caméra mais lui il s'est dit qu'il
travaillait pour stopper et peu qu'on
soit payé alors décida de deux principes
documents top secrets de les amener avec
lui hong kong et après d'aller se
réfugier dans un hôtel peu connu et vous
devez bien vous êtes que c'était la
belle vie parce qu'à chaque journée il
pouvait inviter des amis et cetera mais
non parce qu'il avait toujours les
pressentiments que quoi que ce soit
pouvait arriver
mais quand lui plus de confiance mais je
n'avais rien de secret aux journalistes
j'aimerais vous faire quelques
révélations
la première c'est que avec vos appareils
vous avez pas me rêvais privé parce qu'à
chaque fois vous allez envoyer un
message à vos amis sur vous même sur
votre vie privée
il y aura toujours quelqu'un pour le
voir même si cette personne fait partie
de l' agence on n'a pas vu tout le temps
se faire observer la deuxième c'est que
imaginer un agent double un méchant je
vais prendre pour un an un gentil pour
s'introduire dans la salle pour ensuite
obtenir des renseignements sur quiconque
et après aller lui fasse du mal mais il
ya du positif dans tout cela c'est que
magie un groupe de méchant qui sont en
train de se créer pour leur prochain
coup mais avec ce prototype il peut
découvrir ils peuvent découvrir tout ce
qu ils sont en train de se créer comment
salama fonctionne tout cela si avec une
puce électronique qu'ils insèrent dans
tous les appareils pour comme je le
disais tout à l'heure pour pouvoir voir
tout ce qu'on fait à partir de la caméra
et pour pouvoir voir tout ce qu'on aime
tout ce qu'on écrit à nos amis moi si je
serais vous je sais le dragon des
informations que je viens de vous dire
parce que peut-être qu'il nous apparaît
sont attirantes d'un goût d'aller jouer
décret à nos amis mais lieu de négatif
il faut en tenir compte
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]